Stephen Fry is an actor author comedian
activist and former Twitterer Stephen
thanks for joining me
it's a pleasure David nice to be you are
giving me 10 minutes we're jumping it
we're on Larry King said I got a bonus
ten minutes with you I'm very excited
but you've had a boner is I do have an
effect on people but that's right well
we'll give me give me a couple minutes
okay good start yeah
turn your loop down so everything that
that you're about that I know about you
are the exact things that I talk about
on the show all the time about atheism
and free thinking and secular values all
of these things do you fear for these
things right now because I think they're
in a very precarious position yes I do
David actually and I think I suppose one
would bundle it all up and say one fears
that the advances of the Enlightenment
are being systematically and
deliberately pushed back not
deliberately by everybody because quite
a few people who are doing it don't even
know what the Enlightenment was but I
mean America is an example of a country
that was founded on principles of the
Enlightenment by by people who had read
Kant and and pain and and and and the
philosophers Voltaire and others who had
opened up the idea of free thinking and
casting off the shackles of ecclesiastes
ISM I suppose of being ruled by the
church and and an America was the great
experiment in which all this was to be
it was to be put into the form of a
state a state that was benevolent and
free and open and not ruled by religion
and not ruled by by by enforced thinking
and who went horribly wrong yeah I'm not
taking America's Winrock I just mean
that's you know I mean it went horribly
wrong
unfortunately in terms of within a
hundred years sparking off the the most
bloody civil war in human history just
as an in tonight's into the zone
conflict nothing had been bloody as you
well know so that was a bad thing yeah
and somehow then
crime gang violence started in Chicago
New York and of course the West was
opened up in the bloodiest way
imaginable with genocide and gunfire and
and this the beautiful calm marble
pillars that you think of the elegant
harmonious sort of architecture but the
intellectual architecture and physical
architecture that that America was
supposed to represent became so blood
spattered yeah so you're saying we're
not a perfect society by no means let
are you any less perfect than Britain or
or any other yeah but there's an irony
at the heart of it and I am as you
rightly said an atheist but funnily
enough perhaps more than that I'm not a
rationalist I'm an empiricist I think
there's a very important difference
thinking about thought empirical thought
is about seeing whether something is
true experimenting with it finding out
testing it and sometimes rationalism can
be superstition you know you you can say
rationally that you have this like
Pascal had a rational theory of light
and it took it took mutant poked a hole
and some cardboard right
and that's the empirical way of saying
that it's just look so that's really
just science you're down with science
done with science but a very particular
view yes empirical science is very
important side of it you know I mean of
course writing sums on a blackboard is
important as well but they've got to be
tested so I love the Large Hadron
Collider and things like that but um I
don't know how we got to this raised
that issue well all sort of calorie in
in thinking when it clear honking which
absolute clear thinking which is a
phrase that as you know I value highly
from-from Bertrand Russell but and the
empirical side of it is this and it's
worth thinking countries that have kings
and queens which are rationally stupid
weird ideas are empirically freer and
more socially just than countries
don't consider that look at the world
now look at social justice happiness
freedom and equality in the world and
you're thinking Sweden Denmark Norway
Benelux countries and Britain which does
have very high levels of social justice
and and Holland and these countries have
kings and queens and they had
constitutional monarchies so it isn't
that's what I mean by being empirically
right that's I'm I'm not saying
therefore you must have a king and queen
in order to be free but all I'm saying
is you having one doesn't stop you from
being freer from being opener I mean
these are very open societies Denmark
and Sweden and annoying particularly
open society yeah but they're suffering
a little bit from their openness aren't
they right now with all this immigration
stuff I mean it sounds like some of the
underpinnings of it it is it's becoming
it is becoming problematic as a good
question but that's it and so similarly
I am not necessarily in favor of
separation of church and state and the
reason I'm not is that I come from a
country where church and state are
absolutely like that mm-hmm
and is the most secular society I have
ever experienced has the highest level
of atheism anywhere yeah and America has
separation of church and state and not
only they all believe in God they open
even bloody angels yeah here 74% of
Americans think angels walk on the earth
yeah you told me before sorry
you told me before we started you're
moving here half of the year and yeah
what's it really once you really find
out what that's about you may push that
down a little bit of this country I
don't get me wrong I mean you know the
you love what you what you mark you love
you wouldn't you know I wouldn't mock
some of the sides of America if I didn't
value America so much it's one of the
movies that you've been in that I
absolutely love we talked about it a
second ago was V for Vendetta
interestingly in V for Vendetta the it
was the affair authoritarian right that
was coming after everyone's rights and
everyone's speech and there's an amazing
scene with you and you have this Koran
that you're talking about it you say you
love the imagery of it
all this but it's the right that's
coming effort and I find in America
right now it's the left what people
referring to as the regressive left that
seems to be coming after language and
speech to you do you see that does that
is that happening across the pond
- I suspect it is we fear that it's
going to happen more and more because
American leads and and Britain follows
in all kinds of ways and I think it
started to happen in Britain with the
removal or the attempted removal of
statues of people who are considered
unlikable that were once very beloved
one sided and have become in a very 1984
way unperson 's and suddenly someone
because they were an imperialist Cecil
Rhodes is the example I'm thinking of
who was a who is probably best known in
America because the Rhodes Scholarships
that Americans take to carry Oxford and
he founded the country called Rhodesia
Hansbrough hence its name which is now
Zimbabwe of course and he was the
founder of De Beers and various diamond
things loser it was a real Empire
Builder and he was I'm sure a monster he
once said to being born British was to
have drawn first prize in the lottery of
life right this is a guy yes I think
there's a big statue of him or sculpture
a little something in it is Oxford
College and there's a movement because
we were offended by this because he
stood for you know he stood for values
that we now regard rightly I think as
terrible in her stealing other people's
countries right now particularly a
degree not a good thing to do and
raiding although their mineral wealth
but to remove his statue it strikes me
as being stupid I mean the way to fight
colonialism and the ideas behind that is
not to is not a pull down statues yeah
it is it is to actually to reveal to say
who he is this is who this man was look
at him you yeah so this is occasionally
throw negative yeah and this is like
when in America we now don't they won't
show repeats of the show Dukes of
Hazzard because I had a confederate flag
on it or I'll even here you know Thomas
Jefferson people say well you know it's
known that he was sleeping with one of
his slaves and people say well he was a
rapist and we should know but he also he
also probably freed the slaves yeah I
know it's the good life is complicated
and nobody wants to believe that life is
complicated yeah this is the problem I
suppose you might call it the
infantilism of our culture you know the
food people eat is Pappy soft food that
barely needs a knife and fork to be
equal if you look like that and it's
sugary drinks the grown-ups have with
baseball cap wear a baseball cap on a
baseball field right no where else all
right you understand and don't drink
these drinks once you're over 12 years
old there just don't and above all when
you go for the cinema don't go and see
superheroes eat each other
that's the children do you understand Oh
sounds like somebody didn't get the bad
guy role yes I'm a man did I know it
does weird seriously you know there is
deep infantilism in the culture and and
that extends you know it's loved in in
terms of what people wear and what films
they see but in terms of where they
think they can't bear complexity the
idea that things aren't easy to
understand that there's a mmm but
there's a are you have to think there
are gradations there are you know that
no one wants that they want to be told
or they want to be able to decide and
say this is good this is bad I'm saying
so anything that in any way conflicts
with that is not to be borne and on
student campuses this idea of them oh
yeah trigger warnings there are many
great plays in which contain rapes and
the word rape now is even considered a
raid what rep is to rape yeah well it's
it's an it has an interesting Latin
roots and the word wrapped all comes
from the same root rape island there all
kinds of words from it violate you know
these with their terrible things and
they have to be thought about clearly
but if you say you can't watch you come
on this play you know you can't watch
Titus Andronicus no you can't read it in
a Shakespeare class you can't lead men
Beth because I've got children being
being been killed in it and and you
might trigger something when you were
young that upset you once because uncle
touched you in the nasty place well I'm
sorry
yeah it's a great shame and we're all
very sorry that uncle touched in that
nasty place but you get some of my
sympathy but your self-pity gets
my sympathy because self-pity is the
ugliest emotion in humanity get rid of
it because no one's going to like you if
you feel sorry for yourself
the irony is will feel sorry for you if
you stop feeling sorry for yourself just
grow up yeah
all right I love that hopefully you'll
come back we'll do a proper hour go
crazy yes or no am I gonna get you back
on Twitter I'd love it yeah great love
it I got on that but your Twitter coming
back here hold up
Twitter maybe I gotta maybe all right
well you know where to find it'll be at
Stephen Fry if he ever does return on
Twitter
you
you